britt hume is fox's senior political
analyst and no it's not a chronological
thing as he often says it's a measure of
wisdom so we're happy to have him join
us tonight with his reaction brit this
is the democratic party's top
legislative
goal i mean i don't think anything is
even close
why are they so focused on this
so-called voting rights well i think it
first of all it pleases the base and
biden has been kind of a slave to the to
the left-wing base of his party since he
became president
and it's also something that you know if
enacted
would
enshrine in law
the much loose loosened voter
regulations that prevailed during the
pandemic election year of 2020 right and
it would make it easier for people to
vote easier for people who don't
particularly want to vote to vote or
easier to get them to vote it would also
interfere with uh with ballot security
measures such as voter id
and other such measures which are widely
supported by the american public so this
i think you know you look at it piece by
piece it's not really a set of very
popular measures
but it plays well with the base biden
wants to do it he wants you know he's he
tucker i think
to see this we need to drill down a
little bit how did this happen how did
joe biden get himself into this
predicament yes i think that all the
time he was he was pretty moderate i
always thought after election day in
2020 he was on his way to being
president of the united states with the
house
only narrowly in his party's control and
the senate in republican control there
were two races in georgia that were the
republicans to lose and thanks to
considerable extent to his
administrations
the republicans did lose them yeah and
suddenly the democrats had by the
narrowest of possible margins control
the senate and that's what got visions
of historic sugar plums dancing in joe
biden's head and so this guy that was on
his way to having to deal with the
republican senate and the kind of
moderate you know center-left politics
that he practiced for most of his career
went out the window in favor of this
agenda that he's been embarked on ever
since it hasn't worked well he's now
widely unpopular his party is unpopular
they're looking like they're going to
have a staggering losses potentially
staggering losses in the midterms and
he's out doing this uh he doesn't seem
to know how to sort of change course
it may be too late for him so you're i
think it's such a smart observation it
was getting that much power or or the
appearance of that much power that
wrecked him that little power that he
thought was you know could be converted
into into some kind of historic week i
think he's always felt that you know he
was under the shadow of the great barack
obama yes and you know i think there's
reason to believe barack obama didn't
take him seriously he's obama's famously
quoted as saying you should never
underestimate the ability of joe to eff
things up yeah well
afghanistan and
go down the list things are pretty effed
up under in the in this particular
administration um and you know he's got
an inflation running out of control and
so on and he seems
at sea and what he continues to do is to
try to press forward with this agenda
and
and
most of his parties seem willing to go
along with it although there are a few
holdouts and in this tightly divided
congress it only takes a few to block
his agenda fascinating really smart
great human thank you you bet
well tony fauci testified on capitol
hill today and he would not answer the
most basic questions posed hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else